Ngoài hăng kìa với công, người anh chính thức thái sạm, quá xúc bắt sớm, rất xin của đi lắm rồi.
Giang cho 2,5 xúc bắt sớm, đây trong hề này nhả,
và hơi luôn xin cho các bạn, thì thái này,
nhưng bài hình anh đến cái kìa thái sạm của lớp,
Ví xúc bắt sớm rất xin của đi lắm rồi,
và trình thức cùng bố là bàn hài,
hài mình tạm thăm bài,
rất là bàn hài mình,
chúng ta sẽ có một quay thái sạm,
để chỉ tiết của quà viếp xúc bắt sớm rất xin của đi lắm rồi.
Trong người quan sạm, thì các bạn rất là thái thái sạm,
rất là nhiều những thông tin,
về trứng trình phần mí của các bạn.
Đầu tiên nó là về lúc xin học tập trong khoa,
chúng ta sẽ học theo một lúc xin học tập,
như thế nào và phương pháp học tập chủ đào.
Khi một tất cả theo học tập là ra sao.
Để cho kẻ số 2,
là xe khó rất nhiều,
những mi đi game tặng xa tặng này đánh,
dành cho các bạn hình bạn học xin 2,5 xe tham ra bởi lại phía như nha thái sạm,
từng tóc thật nhiều bởi lại phía này,
và để chứ lại tính độ dùng trứng,